welcome to this video playing Richard S
Jones richard s jones australia isn't
this this isn't this guy originally from
way outs and played him before my yes i
have played him before i played 3 15
minute games against him and lost all
three yeah this is in fact somewhat
strange all that because he's got the
terrible rating for an IM in 15 minutes
l very young very strange and i lost
three games ok let's see what happens
here slav with queen bee three i have
fun tried those lines before and now in
blitz and also entirely matches what
could be three not actually Queen Queen
see to earth plate it's a very similar
but can be a different of black it's not
capturing he captured though so get this
type of position
yeah the nice thing about this um this
some whole line is that white here it
gets this structure with D takes e4 this
typical Slav structure black has
captured without having committed on
himself to any weakening moves like a
four on the queenside as it happens in
the absolute main line with 493 and the
caption my ideas play Queen back to e2
and then look to d1 this is a good spot
for the rook and it makes blacks task of
playing see 5 or a 5 bit tougher if
black plays c5 he even managed that in
the end he always needs to reckon with
my bishop on g2 but this diagonal s-sir
is opened
yeah he's taking some time here I mean I
don't know it in any big in any big
detail this line only nope we need to
look to you one basically that's the
general idea and I go from here white is
also delayed the smooth Knight c3 for a
moment often 93 can be answered with 94
and some trades while this is not the
end of the world black as welcoming some
trades and this is not so easily
possible here yeah I wonder I wonder I
wonder Queen B 6 mm can I do something
against the c5 move you know I'll Knight
c3 he still might play I'm play 94 I
wonder 93 94 night XD for Bishop before
95 could be an idea night x if i have
two should be for just this with the
bishop pair in an open position or an
opening position and Bishop g2 that's 97
which should win wouldn't material
really I should win the exchange so
maybe this is okay and I'm intending my
intention is to play you for here also
efore be should be three would be very
nice against the Queen on b6 and yeah he
went for that yeah well okay he can play
it I mean take stakes 95 he can take
only five and play this position but ok
this was my idea here anyway so I I
won't hesitate too long yeah Bush agree
to 97 wins the exchange getting this for
can't take on with it
with some winter the exchange at least
at least maybe even more yeah you should
take on e5 and play this position after
Bishop takes e4 95b should be 497 back
and then okay you're worse against the
bishop pair but it's still on a position
okay what else is there now will Knight
f6 I take you for plate 97 that's not
helping yeah just now takes d5
I really don't see any alternative well
okay let's first just briefly consider
taking on e5 is probably leading to
nothing okay I'll take here takes on G
to play struck the eighth so leads to
absolutely nothing okay all night will
drop back to the seven now I guess yeah
and now while he will play c5 probably
probably quickly not sure actually what
I'm wondering is it should I remove the
bishop just prophylactically it can
easily get attacked on e4 with Knight f6
for example now I'll do that just just
retreat this so how do I have develop
here could play b3 bishop between arm
Bishop dtunes also also possible
yeah bishop d to push up the two queen
bee to is not good for him brooke d to c
1 and I'll take I'll take them on b7
this is not really good Bishop d2 and
then maybe c5 young maybe c5 I have
push-ups III if I something like a small
edge well okay I don't want to come 425
back in time here I'm actually had in
time at the mode which I didn't really
didn't really recognize him so that's
probably the right decision not trying
to rush things there's this a very old
rule is it by name is ilich up quite
sure that you own that you need to free
up crank position slow fashion could
billions of its really not quite sure I
think it wasn't in the witch okay all
bishops III I think this is quite normal
this smooth activating
Oh doorbell ring
all right that turn was a small package
I can I he hasn't played yet that's fine
yeah always worried that you use lots of
time in those in those cases but didn't
didn't happen okay um I'm ciega he tries
really tries to free himself in a slow
manner I wonder yeah well eff form it
does not really look right young I
wonder about you 45 this could be
playable I know it's wrong I mean it it
is of course playable but I wonder if it
is doing anything before five God gives
up d5 and it's not it's not so
attractive without having a night mmm is
there some way to to prevent if I or two
when I was thinking about before but he
also has got the movie 5 normally after
a five I have d5 but after I've played
before if I've d5 is not so easily
possible maybe just just anonymous
interesting also what's Queenie one
threatening Bishop f5 okay well now that
that's even more interesting because the
bishop 185 is really annoying
okay it is a very very crude threat of
course very easy to see but the problem
is what is he doing against it it's not
so easy let's say queen a seven knife
Bishop f5 and you okay okay you can mix
the rook away but i think i've gained
something um and well what what exactly
is like doing now quincy seven Bishop f5
is also not very nice one just down this
sensor not very nice assume it is just
not good okay yeah that's a good idea
actually Queen can come all the way over
to to age five well that's true
hmm that's a bit of a shame really
underestimated this move
yeah h5 there now the queen is looking a
bit silly only one so probably this
wasn't a really good idea
hmm yeah what to do
okay maybe this is an idea well the
Queen trait is you know I don't know if
it happen helps me but to be honest the
real issue is that I'm not threatening
to take on b5 as this would really help
black what does that didn't really
really think of it
hmm that's a strange move really
yeah the Queen ER does not have many
squares
I can do something like this this should
see two coming Queen takes bishop see
two traps the Queen
not so clear that the bishop is doing
anything create on your father yeah
that's just remarkable
mm okay i can go to d5 he can go to d5
no no
Oh
yeah I completely forgot Queen d5 I mean
yeah it's still it's still a risky
business yeah the queen is not having a
great great deal of squares I came the
ship and t3
still aching go 25 m ok this was my
original IDM and going going with that
yeah I'm not sure maybe we can you get
25 I mean I get that I have stuff like
Bishop c4 trying to just perpetually
attack the Queen I can go to g6 maybeee
425 efore Queen h5 the should be tool
should be to Queen g6e five and then I'm
just attacking the Queen on and on there
should be two twenty-five
should be to 25 push-ups
there should be two twenty-five Bishop
c4 26 as possible
look a five is also interesting but
probably c 5s is right then and then I
can play we should be tuned okay d 5
looks very very tricky for black having
this kind of self pin with the e5 and f4
and stuff in fact I can take de Bishop
b5 Bishop b2 and de 95 Bishop b5 Bishop
e5f for ya and then be no Bishop e2 I
thought just them taking the Queen
you know the question is do I have more
than a draw really probably not if if at
all 25 days d take c5 this should be
very nice actually
yeah 25 25 Queen f5 can tribe should be
three again yeah or is there anything
better I guess not
yeah I don't really know is there
anything better than perpetually
attacking the Queen I don't think so i
can maybe be four actually this this
could be an idea before Queen f5 and
then be four using this fifth-ranked pin
now that that might be an idea
maybe he can play Queen g6 but I can
still play Bishop d3 and that's the
absolute same same thing okay let's do
that I'm really not here to play draws
all the time so trying to fight not sure
if it is what this is how to assess the
position I think he probably will play
b6 here this looks like like the way to
go b6 rook takes a 6 and maybe seat XD
form it should be i'm ok for black I
guess
yeah two hours I really don't see
anything else than B 6 cm Quincy to Roxy
one I mean the sister like needing
nowhere so is there some some tactical
something no wow really he's allowing me
to take would be take c5 that that's
that's interesting that's some tactical
thing I don't I don't understand it
really I could be six on yeah well I
mean I take it anyway whatever maybe
there is some sort of be 60 on bc b six
takes on b6 samsung tactics on or e five
see it going for a five and I don't know
I e5 this Bishop d3 air okay Bishop d3
is not leading to too much
curious I really thought b6 would be the
only move ready that's some technical
idea I don't know night be a to c 6
something like that what I really would
like is to to return with fly bish
appear from only to return to the long
diagonal this would be would be really
good possible ideas screen you one
actually quit you one Bishop f12 g2 it's
a bit slow but very desirable from a
strategic point of view there is also
the simple move Queen g2 in some cases
while he will get in lots of time travel
here one minute something yes this is
the most forcing way to do it queen is
not exactly having many squares but one
problem is he sort of threatens to take
on different take on c5 as the c3 bishop
is hanging that's um that's a bit of a
problem
yup d 3 there is Queen to f3 after which
I don't really have a good move
how to how to get a better coordination
here the the bishop on c3 is a problem
really it is always hanging I wonder if
rook a3 might be an idea actually wrote
a three yeah I've i'm also not exactly
having lots of time just this just
protects the bishop and maybe a lousy
shot a five at some moment yeah I wanted
to take with the pawn anyway so bishop
yeah maybe now Bishop f3s standing a bit
in strength as the brook is on the third
rank so you should be three okay let's
let's play this first and then work out
the details later
if he goes here I can play Bishop back
to be too threatening Bishop h7s is a
bit annoying oh it's not splitting up at
all you need to play to play mafia 20
seconds ok Bishop c4 all right this was
an idea improving it with temple and
let's see maybe you could be less Roxy 5
possibly threatened it's not not that
easy actually knight c6 is also also
coming I can play rook be three though
attacking b7 now that's a good move I
think 96 rook here attacking on f7 yeah
okay he will lose it on time and maybe
this is some black for FX are entirely
this is the reason why his writing is so
low here for an IM he beat me three
times sent to me ball played yeah I
don't know it looks it looked ok I think
but jump
very very tough very tough struggle I
mean right here this 95 should really
give give white something let's just go
back thank you should play b6 really
this this this one spot yeah here I went
here this all looks normal really you
know this should be always a bit better
for wide the two bishops bit a little
bit more in the center no but blackest
is very very very very solid of course
and e6 and now Queen us actually
supported by the computer and now it
wants to play b3m yeah maybe maybe I'm
not really too fond of this Queen f1
move in retrospect it's the thing is it
is a move that is not threatening
anything because I will never take care
but this really only dawned on me after
I played it to be honest but you went
here and grab this poem is which looks
which looked very risky to me but ok it
seemed to be ok the problem was it
looked very risky to me because my
original idea was bishop see turu k1
trapping the queen but there is no trap
of the queen because it can simply drop
back here and well I have nothing ok
this is what I what I went for and this
maneuver now I get this attack on the
Queen yeah I don't know here he went
when Drew k5 and he played this movie 5
which looks really risky in a way he
could have think but it's it's always as
always tricky maybe you could have
played that
queen is short of squares but how do I
trap it the computer does not see a
queen win that just sees this sort of
Perpetual queen chase which is probably
the in a way the logical outcome of the
game but he was actually a head on time
and played c5 after which okay i played
this first then I be then okay we had
this couple of more times and then I
played before yeah and here I really
thought that he should play b6 isn't
this like okay I don't know a computer
actually wants to play this move which
is also very interesting I actually
dismiss that out right because of rooks
e1 and I thought okay what's the point
I'll take next move computer however
points out this Queen sec which is in
fact very interesting this could easily
be very much okay for black stock who
shares on equal interesting like has
some look minor piece and pawn or two
points actually two ponds yeah that's
certainly okay for black but at least
first lens i would say that should be
okay yeah i didn't see that in the game
but the well be six was what I thought
look 86 and then taking here takes takes
takes and i thought this should be in a
way okay for black of course my looks
are active and b6 is slightly weak but i
thought that with precise play that
should this should be equal computer
gives an IT five as being completely
equal
okay this is not a totally trivial move
because it gives up b6 but i cannot
really take it i believe if i would
check let's say go for that or is
queenie form tending Knight f3 yeah
engine says equal yeah we'll be six was
what i would have thought but he allowed
me to take and this should really be
very good for right now I've got a very
nice structure space advantage bishops
b7 this week so yeah well the real deal
was the time I guess he recognized what
he had done and went for for this okay
this is probably not the most best and
the best move but what is the computer
giving that's very tough this move but
it's good it's a very good move rock d
three now that's not so easy to do for
for a human with limited time it's very
strong very strong and this is the kind
of move once you see it at least now I
can tell you once I see it I see that is
very strong but to actually spot it it's
not so easy why is this a strong move it
does the same a little bit of the same
what I did it protects you three so that
let's say this is not possible anymore
because it's protected here and it
prepares the very strong maneuver Queen
to d1 and Bishop f3 and the Queen on d1
is of course much much better than on f1
and it's behind the rook so very nicely
using the power of both heavy pieces at
the very very strong move yeah this this
is letting him off the hook of it
because not this move but ok he was
essentially almost sure to lose on time
here well night f8 was a good one
intending 96 why it is still better but
it's not like I'm winning immediate
they rocked III was much more forceful
here's something like like this I could
do for example I mean it's it's still
nice yeah there's two bishops and so on
but it's not so apparent how to to get
ahead Ianto here yes it's just just a
very nice position I think oh yeah rugby
3 wasn't good really there should be two
was better you know this failed said
this is this little tactical and feylis
a bit much but black can play b5 here
typical computer like trick that's also
tough to spot cannot take here because a
whoopsie find the Queen on h5 is
attacking new one so after b5 I would
actually need to go back and then this
isn't really accomplished much ok well
in the game he basically i overstepped
the time hereafter would be 7 this now
of course really really gone as f
sadness is going to go into collapse
there's no no defense anymore you can do
that it's a funny tactical move but
Queenie to is simple and and strong
check this is not leading to anything
check you know that's out of checks and
now white is having all the fun yeah
very tough game now thanks for watching